We're looking at my blood test and tumor markers, which one is most important?
So a lot of people will get tumor markers done.
If you got them done through us, I have put together the female tumor marker panel and
the male tumor marker panel.
Now, again, what are tumor markers?
There are proteins that cancers can give off.
Now, the operative word there is can, or may give off, maybe that's better grammar.
They may, certain cancers may expel these different proteins, and then we can measure
them.
But they don't always.
You could have stage 4 raging cancer and not show any positive lab test elevations of
tumor markers.
Why?
But I don't know.
It's just what it is.
But it can be used if you do show elevations in tumor markers with your cancer.
It can be used as another objective scale that you can measure progress in any course of care.
So which ones are most important?
Well, it partly depends on what type of cancer you have.
So the female tumor marker panel is, I remember off the top of my head, it's CA-153.
Now, CA-153 is only going to really show up in breast cancer.
CA-199.
CA-199 can show up in breast cancer, but it's a primary marker of pancreatic cancer.
CA-25-27, or 27-29, that's only going to be, well, it's usually going to be just breast
cancer.
CA-153 is, can be across multiple different cancers.
And CA-125, which could also be positive in multiple different cancers.
Which one is most important?
There is one that's most important.
So whichever shows up on you, and we want to use that as a marker, well, what if this shows
up and this doesn't?
This one went up and this one went down.
Again, you're just using those as clues to what's going on.
Remember, any blood test, any test is just a clue.
It's just giving us clues of what could be going on.
You're helping that with looking at other objective and subjective data to come up with the differential
diagnosis of which direction you think the cancer is going and what interventions might be
the wisest to take.
So there isn't the cancer marker or tumor marker that's more important than the other.
We're just looking at changes in that.